معلومات العسكريه الوارده من هذه المنطقه
جاءت على لسان قائد مجموعه
تسيطر بشكل شبه كامل على المدينه من ثلاث
محاور لم يبقى الا محور وهو غرب المدينه
والذي يؤدي الى منطقه
تشافي سيار وهي عباره عن تله تبعد بمساحه
خمسه عشر كيلو متر من منطقه بحموت يبدو ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ارسلت في الايام
الاخيره تعزيزات لهذه المنطقه لكي يكون
لها منطقه اطلاق نار مرتفعه على منطقه
بحموت وهو ما يفسر على انه اعتراف من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه بصعوبه البقاء في مدينه
وباتت السيطره الروسيه على هذه المدينه
شبه امر واقع خاصه وان القوات التابعه
لمنظمه تسيطر من ثلاثه مواقع اذا من
الناحيه العمليه ومن الناحيه العسكريه
من البقاء في منطقه محاصره من ثلاث مناطق
اي ان الهزيمه هي مساله وقت وان سبعه اشهر
من القتال ادت الى هذا الوضع
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه لاحتلال هذه المنطقه
على ما يبدو اتت اكلها وببتت هذه المنطقه
شبه يعني محسومه للقوات الروسيه ماذا يعني
السيطره على هذه المنطقه يعني السيطره
والاستقرار في منطقه الدومباس هذه المنطقه
الواقعه شرق اوكرانيا تسعى القوات الروسيه
يعني السيطره عليها كما تعلمين منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب
قائد مجموعه فاقنر قال اودعاء الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودي الى اخراج قوه بلاده
وهذا يعزز ربما ما قاله سابقا نعود لنذكر
ربما وكنت قد بدات بذلك عن اهميه هذه
المدينه التي باتت ربما مركز المعارك في
الشرق نعم هي منطقه مهمه من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه للسيطره على منطقه او احكام
السيطره على منطقه الدومباس هي ايضا منطقه
مهمه من الناحيه الصناعيه وهي تحتوي على
مصانع للمعدات الثقيله تعتمد
كييف عليها بشكل كبير اذا يسيطر على هذه
المنطقه
يضعف ويوجه ضربات اخرى الى الاقتصاد
الاوكراني ويشدد الخناق على يعني
في موقف حرج امام الشعب الاوكراني خاصه
وانه في ديسمبر من العام الماضي كان قد
تواجد في هذه المنطقه بعد انتصار القوات
الاوكرانيه في معركه ازوم وسيطر على ايزوم
كان هو في هذه المنطقه وصرح بان القوات
الاوكرانيه ستتمسك في منطقه
دافع باي ثمن كان او باي تكلفه عن هذه
المنطقه وستبقى اوكرانيه اذا الانتصار في
هذه المعركه هو غ
الرئيسكي وهو انتصار معنوي
ويعني استراتيجي لروسيا
سيكون في موقف حرج في هذه الفتره خاصه وان
روسيا تحضر لما يعرف بمعركه الربيع وهذه
المعركه هي معركه تريد منها روسيا احكام
السيطره بالكامل على منطقه
وكذلك منع القوات الاوكرانيه من استخدام
المساعدات الاوروبيه بما يتعلق او حلف
الناتو بما يتعلق
بالدبابات المدرعه الالمانيه وغيرها من
الاسلحه التي وعدت يعني الدول الاوروبيه
وحلف الناتج بايصالها للقوات الاوكرانيه
ايضا يريد ان يستبق بقطع امل الانتصار في
اي معركه وخاصه معركه الربيع
ايضا قد ذهبت الى المنطقه لافادتنا
بالمستندات على الارض شكرا لك